when I see someone I have a crush on
does my heart literally skip a beat no
but it can speed up and you could even
have something known as a PVC like a PVC
is a premature ventricular contraction
or your heart like beats but nothing
really happens so it's like an
incomplete beat if you will but they
happen rarely and without symptoms
usually pretty benign so the answer is
Maybe
help I fart really hard and it hurts how
do I fix this doesn't is there a name
fart splints or something Sam you know
what it is
painful part
the answer is what's going on sometimes
there's hemorrhoids and there's two
different types of hemorrhoids internal
and external external is usually the
ones you feel because they're past a
pectate line there's also anal fissures
that can bleed quite quite badly you can
actually end up getting a cream that's
called nifedipine it's compounded with
usually some lidocaine or some other
numbing agent that allows that sphincter
to relax a bit and heal better there are
surgeries obviously but those are from
more advanced cases someone please tell
me if you had no bones could you still
move no
no well no no
well
because your muscles are attached to
bones and if you have no bones the
muscles aren't attached to anything so
you couldn't move why do vegetables
taste bad why can't they just taste good
I disagree I think an asparagai in my
mouth after a steak is wonderful
asparagai right when there's multiple
I'm Googling it
it's either asparagus or asparaguses I
take back my asparagai okay there are no
asparagus in my mouth only asparaguses
that sounds weird
I'm 25 years old I've never had a
nosebleed I would very much like to
experience one how would you no what is
why what am I reading
how do I know if I have a slow
metabolism whether I need to speed it up
unless there's an issue meaning you're
struggling to lose weight and you've
been documented to be overweight and
there's a health condition that's being
impacted by the fact that you're
overweight I wouldn't worry about your
metabolism per se and in general the
things that you would do to live a
healthy lifestyle will help you maintain
a healthy metabolism I wouldn't think
about it as slower or faster because a
too faster metabolism is also
problematic and too slow is problematic
so ideally you want to balance
metabolism and a balanced metabolism is
one that comes with a healthy lifestyle
obviously there are some factors outside
of your control but that's when diseases
happen and that's when a doctor should
intervene all of your hiccup cures are
just the top results on Google what
makes you any better than just Googling
what's wrong with me I guess you can
it's just Google's going to give you a
lot of info and it's going to be in text
and boring versus here we're having fun
and enjoying the time together hey how
are you doing how you doing
I've been having a lot of problems with
excessive sweating I know you've dealt
with this a lot so do you have any
advice become okay with sweating it's a
good piece of advice and I've become
better with it understanding that it's
kind of part of life there are
prescription strength deodorants that
you could use you could even use them on
your palms if that happens there there
are injections like botox that you can
inject directly into sweat glands I've
never went down this route but I've
heard people do it and I've met doctors
that do it with good results you just
have to do it maybe a couple times in
order to get longer lasting results I
don't know I kind of just sweat and live
you got so triggered in your last meme
review by people saying they shower at
night I shower at night because it keeps
my bed cleaner when I go to sleep do you
really think showering the morning is
better
yes and they take a passionate stance on
this and I want to argue with everybody
in the comment section that I prefer to
shower in the morning and that's the
logical way to go let's lay out a list
of pros and cons of showering in the
morning versus at night let's say you
shave very frequently and you get some
Nicks Sometimes maybe it's better shower
in the morning why because you have more
platelets in the morning interest
interesting fun medical fact let's say
you're stressed out when you wake up in
the morning or you need a little
creativity bump it's a good time to do
it right there in the morning and you
know what you do at night you sweat
usually more than you sweat during the
day with the exception of exercise
obviously you're gonna have oil in the
night you're gonna have sweat in the
night clogged pores the night so waking
up in the morning and showering gets you
ready for the day cleans off your body
and makes you ready to go on the only
thing I would say is if you're going to
shower in the morning shower a little
bit cooler because warmer might make you
sleepy you want to go back to bed but
now for the people I like to shower at
night ideally if you are doing this it
can help you fall asleep especially if
you do it like 90 minutes before you
keep it short like 5 to 15 minutes
because if you're exposed to a lot of
heat for longer than that it could
actually be activating instead of
sedating benefits obviously throughout
the day you get dirty oil all that stuff
and therefore you might not want to
bring that into bed which can be
acnegenic causing some clogged pores and
stuff also might be better to shower at
night if your sun senses if because if
you exfoliate for example and you go out
in the sun that might be a problem
because your Skin's more sensitive but
if you exfoliate at night for the
morning you're ready to take on the day
and probably the best reason for most
people that have allergies to shower at
night is because you wash off all the
pollen that you got on you and then you
don't bring it into bed so you sneeze
less do what that what you will but for
me morning shower and like post exercise
obviously because you don't want yeast
and all that stuff developing did you
become a doctor because your father
forced you because I think you'd be a
better comedian okay you're probably
being sarcastic no my father didn't
force me and I would not be a better
stand-up comedian I would like to try my
hand at it I kind of did on the live
tour and I had like two good jokes in
order to see them you have to come to
the next edition of the life tour
whatever that's happening is bear in a
Jeep Grand Cherokee commercial there is
a Newfoundland dog named bear in the
Jeep Grand Cherokee commercial and I am
kind of upset that they didn't use my
bear bear you know you're in a
commercial come here have you been
secretly going out and earning in the
night Jeep Grand Cherokee ends I should
get at least a little I feed you
well I don't care if you're working
without my permission come here but you
do need your working papers all right
son just next time if you do a
commercial can you do it for like a
Lamborghini so they give us one for free
do people actually Sleepwalk how could I
make sure it never happens to me you
can't make sure but if you sleep well
you sleep the same number of hours
consistently you don't take any
substances that impact your sleep the
risk of your sleepwalking decreases but
you can't be 100 protective of it is it
normal to have migraines every single
day no absolutely not in fact while we
have medications that are abortive in
nature that stop migraines there's also
medications that are preventive in
nature and that prevent migraines from
coming on and you should discuss those
with your doctor and not all of them are
labeled migraine medications some of
them are like heart rate medications
that like beta blockers that actually
help with migraines or antidepressants
that can be used off label for migraines
so worth a discussion when the doctor
asks if I'm on any prescription drug
should I tell him I'm using prescription
toothpaste or does that not count
I've yet to hear about prescription
toothpaste but absolutely it counts it
should be are you taking anything period
like prescription or non-prescription
those things still have side effects so
I don't even understand the distinction
between the two unless you're asking to
refill a prescription to send something
to the pharmacy I never just ask my
patients are you taking any medications
is are you taking any medications are
you taking any supplements any creams
Etc so toothpaste absolutely falls into
that category
prescription to this because that's not
just like a regular over-the-counter
product are breads that have a bunch of
visible seeds in them actually healthier
than bread that doesn't or is that just
a marketing trick to Sea pumpkin well
first of all Lizzy some people enjoy
those seeds like for example I like
bread with pumpkin seeds or sunflower
seeds on it I think there's a big factor
to be had with flavor there's also
different macros that come with those
breads because depending on the type of
seed you may increase the protein
concentration also the big hack that
comes from having seeds is fiber if you
don't mind the seeds I I add them on can
I become more tolerant of mental health
medication 30 milligrams used to do the
trick but it doesn't feel like it has
the same effect anymore have I gotten
used to it it really depends which
medication you're talking about because
some medications absolutely do have a
tolerance building effect Xanax as an
example like those are benzodiazepines
the answer is it depends do you have a
workout playlist you can share I don't I
just like use Dance Workout playlist
actually I can show you a picture of it
workout music hits 2023 it's a really
random playlist but I like it is it
better to hydrate myself with warm or
cold water it's probably no perfect
answer to that really cold not ideal
really hot above 140 we've seen rates of
esophageal cancer going up so again stay
away from the extremes what is the
actual risk of drinking alcohol if
you're on painkillers what could
actually happen well it depends which
painkillers you're talking about if
you're talking about opioids obviously
there's the risk of respiratory
depression and then if you pass out you
can aspirate your own vomit and die when
you're drinking alcohol you're less
likely to make good decisions so you
could take too much of the painkiller
and OD when it comes to like stuff like
Tylenol takes a load onto your liver
because your liver actively needs to
filtrate it and in fact some of the
biggest hospitalizations for liver
failure come from an overuse of
acetaminophen which is the active
ingredient in Tylenol and then when it
comes to like the Advils and motrins of
the world these are NSAIDs Mount
steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs and
those can actually have an impact on
your stomach lining which then by
drinking alcohol which irritates the
stomach lining kind of has a doubling
effect of irritation causing worsening
gastritis especially if you have an
ulcer is it true that eating poppy seeds
on a bagel can cause you to fail a drug
test how long does it take for those
seeds to clear your system you know it's
a good question I don't know but
anecdotally I have heard this to be true
specifically in like armed forces and
police officer exams they tell you not
to use those products is it healthy to
and safe to eat insects like crickets
I'm seeing them become more popular here
in Europe and I'm skeptical if they've
been prepared by an adequate food agency
I don't know what the equivalent of FDA
is in Europe then I don't see why that
would be a problem eating them fresh off
the ground I can imagine that somethings
could go wrong I don't know not really a
wildlife expert she's playing chess and
exercise because when I play my heart
rate goes way up you know I used to
think it no but there's been articles
coming out of individuals losing a
significant number of pounds while
playing chess and tournaments you know
glucose feeds the brain so it obviously
Burns some calories your heart rate goes
up I would say that it's an imperfect
exercise because it doesn't make you use
of your muscles your musculoskeletal
system and as a result you can develop
aches pains by being in the same locked
in position I would say incomplete
exercise but a good exercise nonetheless
a Val what time of day is best for
working out can I make more progress
going in the morning for example is
there a time of day the body's more
primed for exercise I've seen this go
both ways within my patient population
even for myself for example if I'm going
to do a low intensity long exercise
session doing it at night doesn't bother
me actually helps me fall asleep real
well but if I was to do Sprints and
doing them close to bedtime at night
when I dump all of that adrenaline it's
actually hard to fall asleep but I need
some time to wind down also some people
are not early morning risers so when
they wake up they don't feel great that
works also even more both ways that some
people will start exercising and feel
better therefore that's kind of their
hack to getting started and other people
just don't get good adequate performance
and they would prefer to work out later
in the day but medically speaking we
don't have a thorough answer for that
you said sweating more means you pee
less does the same apply to crime crying
can I cry so much I never pee never pee
no because you're still going to be
using liquids unless you stop drinking
and then you keep crying ultimately your
tears would dry up probably before your
pee in fact if I see a child in the
emergency room and their lips are dry
and they're crying and I don't see tears
I'm really worried about dehydration why
do I get hiccups anytime I eat any
really spicy foods oh that's probably
because you're irritating your diaphragm
and your diaphragm starts to have like a
spasm in it if you take like an inhale
then a little bit more inhale without
exhaling and then another one real quick
really fast and really hard it actually
stops the hiccup I don't know how it
like paralyzes your diaphragm or
something what advice do you have about
whether a patient should go see a doctor
that works in a giant hospital and a
healthcare system for seeing a doctor
with a small local Private Practice I
think most days doctors that are even
local Private Practice are affiliated
with bigger institutions I'm a fan of
having a small local physician that you
have a good rapport with and a
long-standing relationship with and then
if something is outside of their
practice or their abilities to help you
they have a health care System behind
them that they can refer you to but a
giant Hospital could be really good if
you have a rare condition or obviously
like a level one trauma or something
like that why do I keep getting charlie
horses in my legs when I'm trying to
sleep at night most commonly for young
healthy athletic people this happens as
a result of fatigue if you over fatigue
muscle especially if you start a new
exercise regimen you go a little too
hard you could start developing those
types of cramps also there's obviously
issues with electrolytes in some people
that are maybe dehydrated or they're not
just taking in enough electrolytes how
can I learn to swallow a pill oh there's
actually really useful diagrams on
Harvard that they show I'm showing them
here about using a water bottle where
you actually suck the water bottle and
allows you to swallow the pill better
obviously there's certain pills that you
can crush and like sprinkle into yogurt
or applesauce or something just be
careful not all pills are able to do
that make sure you read the instructions
really carefully why does a baby become
comforted by a pacifier it tricks the
baby into thinking they're being fed I
presume it's the suck reflex
um so makes sense I'm not a huge fan
because it changes the development of
the baby's mouth I try to minimize
pacifier use or at least encourage my
patients to minimize pacifier use but
that being said I understand a crying
baby is very difficult so I understand
the need for a pacifier is rosacea a bad
thing I've always had it but always
thought it was just one of my beauty
traits well it really depends what's
causing your red cheeks a lot of times
doctors will say it's rosacea but it
could be rosacea plus something else I
would more so look at the symptoms how
much they're bothering you what else is
going on in your body generally speaking
rosacea is just kind of a blood vessel
issue that causes some discoloration on
your skin that usually is localized to
the area but not in every case sometimes
rosacea can be paired with autoimmune
conditions for example or rosacea can be
diagnosed when there's really a more
correct diagnosis like lupus and you get
the butterfly rash so you got to be
really careful when it comes to rashes
Chris Collins AKA call me Chris actually
shared some really intimate stories on
this podcast I highly recommend you
check out the checkout podcast with
Chris Collins as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]